Saved by the Bell is a beloved touchstone
for '90s kids everywhere. But for all its
wholesome hijinks, the show's set was more than
a little sordid. These are the hook-ups, parties,
and weirdest fashion choices that went on
behind the scenes of Saved by the Bell.
You may be surprised to learn that
Bell started off as a completely
different show called Good Morning, Miss
Bliss. The pilot episode aired in 1988,
starring Hayley Mills, a British
actress, as the titular Miss Bliss.
The show lasted for 13 episodes on the
Disney Channel before it got canceled.
When Miss Bliss didn't make it in the ratings,
executive producer Peter Engel went back to the
drawing board. The series was retooled into Saved
By the Bell, taking four cast members with it:
Mark-Paul Gosselaar as Zachary "Zack" Morris,
Dustin Diamond as Samuel "Screech" Powers,
Lark Voorhies as Lisa Turtle, and Dennis
Haskins as Mr. Belding. Brian Austin Green
and Jaleel White also appeared in a scrapped
pilot of Miss Bliss, but did not make the jump.
Though Miss Bliss takes place in
Indianapolis, Engel decided to move
the kids to California. He also changed
the age range of the kids on the show,
from eighth graders to full blown high-schoolers.
Saved by the Bell's beloved Zack Morris was
inspired by another high school smart aleck:
Ferris Bueller. As Gosselaar detailed
to Jimmy Fallon, he snagged quite a lot
of swagger from that cinematic slacker.
Morris' infamous moments of breaking the
fourth wall to speak to the audience, for
example, are directly inspired by Bueller.
"That was done by Ferris Bueller,
we were just copying him."
Similarly, the character of A.C.
Slater was inspired by Vinny Barbarino,
the character John Travolta made famous
on the '70's sitcom Welcome Back, Kotter.
"The first thing you gotta do is the
Vinny Barbarino look. Okay? Your hair
for instance. Very casual. It should look
like it's being blown by unseen winds."
Engel recalled:
"Slater was supposed to be
Vinny with a leather jacket.
Italian kid, who was a street kid, an army brat."
Mr. Belding was also inspired by someone
else, but not in a way the man in question
might have liked: The character
was named after Richard Belding,
a pain-in-the-butt editor Engel
had to work with at Universal.
Lisa Turtle's name came from a real girl Engel
knew, and Slater was named after a friend of
Engel's son in kindergarten. By the way, the
A.C. in A.C. Slater stands for Albert Clifford.
While Gosselaar, Diamond, Haskins, and
Voorhies all made the move to Bell,
Jennie Garth, who was up to play Kelly Kapowski,
didn't get the role. She went on to major success,
however, on Beverly Hills 90210. Which might have
been for the best, since not everyone who did get
cast in Saved by the Bell was thrilled about it:
Mario Lopez initially didn't want to play Slater,
and admits in his autobiography he was
more interested in chasing girls than,
quote, "trekking up to L.A. to read for a part
that had barely been sketched out on paper."
Engel reportedly fought to have Tiffani Amber
Thiessen on the show, knowing she was, quote,
"going to be a major star." Elizabeth Berkley
was also up to play Kelly, but wound up
playing Jessie, a much smarter, more evolved
character specifically created for Berkley.
As she reflected on Bethenny, she
wasn't super into her wardrobe, saying:
"Just because you are a feminist,
why can't you also dress in things that
make you feel girly and empowered?"
As you watch even the most wholesome family
sitcom, you just can't help but wonder:
Who's hooking up with whom behind the
scenes? Unsurprisingly, putting a bunch
of teenagers together resulted in a whole
lot of romance on the Saved by the Bell set.
(couples kiss, audience "whoo")
As Gosselaar told People:
"All of us dated at one point
or another — it was incestuous!"
While much of what went on behind the
scenes was innocent, some of it became
messy. As Lopez details in his memoir, he dated
Thiessen, but did not stay faithful, admitting:
"I can't say that I was capable at that age
of following through on my noble intentions.
There was so much beauty everywhere
and I had so much affection to share."
With Saved By the Bell being full of teens,
it's no surprise they did some partying.
Theissen has admitted the first time she
sipped alcohol was with Gosselaar in Paris
during a press tour. Gosselaar told ABC News
he did the time-honored show biz tradition
of using his celebrity to get into adult
clubs at the age of 16, although he insisted:
"But I didn't abuse it, and neither did my
castmates. I can't stress how good we were."
Most of us probably have regrets
about our high school hair,
and the Saved By the Bell gang is
no exception. Many fans don't know
that Gosselaar is a natural brunette who had to
bleach his hair blond for every single episode.
“When they sent me the notes on you last night,
it said you dyed your hair
blonde for every single episode.”
"For six years! I'm surprised I have
hair! I can't believe I have hair now."
Gosselaar's hair style looked different
every season because, surprisingly enough,
the Bell gang thought every
season would be their last.
The show ultimately lasted six
years, but as Gosselaar explained:
"At the end of [every] season, we
all left, we said goodbye to each
other. And that's why every season my
hairstyle was so radically different."
Hair drama spared no one. Not even AC Slater.
"I didn't even know I had a mullet,
it was like an unintentional mullet."
Elizabeth Berkley had trouble keeping
her wild, curly hair under control,
and was subjected to endless procedures,
treatments, and techniques. The actress recalled:
"They diffused my hair, flipped it, teased it,
sprayed it with hairspray. I practically
went through a can of hairspray a show."
One of the most infamous and parodied Saved
By the Bell episodes is "Jessie's Song."
In it, Jessie gets hooked on
caffeine pills and finally has
a breakdown in Zack's arms as she sings
the Pointer Sisters hit, "I'm So Excited."
"I'm so excited, I'm so excited, I'm so… scared."
This moment is widely derided as cheesy,
melodramatic, and unintentionally funny.
What few know is that this scene was
initially going to be a lot more serious.
As Engel has detailed, Jessie was
originally going to be hooked on speed,
but NBC's Standards and Practices stepped in
and told him to tone the episode down.
Still, the point came across. Engel said:
"Today, when I meet fans of the show, 'Jessie's
Song' is almost always the episode that comes up
first. No one was making programming for kids
like that at the time. It made an impact. It
helped them grow up. And I'm still, to this
day, proud to have my name on that episode."
Like so many child stars, the Bell cast got
screwed by the deal they signed. At the time, no
one suspected that Saved by the Bell would become
a huge phenomenon. Being young and naïve, the
stars signed iffy contracts, meaning they didn't
make anywhere near as much money as you'd think.
"We made really bad deals. Poor deals back then."
"It is what it is. You move on, you learn."
Moreover, the cast do not make money from the
show's syndication, nor from its merchandise.
Everyone makes mistakes when they're young,
but most of us don't have to live with the
knowledge that those mistakes are still
costing us thousands of dollars every day.
Dustin Diamond fell on hard
times after the show ended.
The past few decades have been
littered with scandal and arrests.
Most infamously, he wrote a salacious
tell-all book, 2009's Behind the Bell.
Its veracity is forcefully
disputed by his former castmates.
"I'm guessing you have not
read that, or have you?"
"I've read excerpts."
"This guy's such a d---."
To some degree, Diamond seems to agree with their
point of view. In recent years, he has claimed
that his ghostwriter, quote, "fabricated a whole
bunch of stuff," and that he was "railroaded."
So that's a bummer. But you know what isn't?
Dennis Haskins, who played Mr. Belding,
finally graduated college
in 2015 at the age of 65,
earning a Bachelor of Arts in
theater and speech. For his part,
Haskins looks back fondly on his time as part
of a much-beloved TV classic, saying in 2013:
"I knew it was something special because
the energy was different. The kids were a
little bit older, the dynamic was great between
everybody, and we were having a great time."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.